[Music]
current trend among happiness
researchers is optimism meaning and I
can understand that you know just wasn't
the case 10 or 15 years ago there is a
great deal of debate as to the value of
life satisfaction and whether this is
what we're trying to maximize I have in
the past
proposed that we should put a lot of
emphasis on what people experience in
their daily life which is a completely
different thing from life satisfaction
but if you know I I think about what's
been going on today and one thing that
hasn't been mentioned and that has to do
with well-being if there is a huge
asymmetry between people's responses to
gains and to losses and there is a huge
asymmetry between winners and losers and
losers suffer more than winners and joy
and so in in this whole issue you know
we have to think about losers and losers
fight harder than winners so potential
winners and that is where reforms in
general fail or very frequently fail is
because the potential losers fight much
farther than the potential winners and I
I would think that at least in the short
run when we are trying to understand
what is going on that thinking
dynamically about losers and winners in
the current change and what other losers
going to do and the phrase that people
will rise before machine do before
machines do that I think is something
that we should really focus on the issue
of what we are trying to maximize is
interesting but that leads me to another
question I'm impressed that there's a
lot of optimism here tempered
and as we saw in the last session but
but we've been complaining about what
everybody has been complaining about the
versus not a decent society and so on
and I certainly concur we can't be
optimistic
if the trend in the culture and in the
politics goes the other way what I do
not understand is we have a culture that
is built on on work on the idea of work
and we have a culture that's deeply
individualistic and that is against
redistribution we have a political
culture in when we look at the trend of
AI and at the political and social
situation I see less reason for optimism
then then was expressed to them in the
you know it's we all complain about the
society but what are we going to do and
the answer is we are not going to do
anything that they're going to affect
that or very little it's society that is
going to respond and how we are going to
do that is not clear well I didn't
answer your question but a little bit um
so one of the things you got the Nobel
Prize for inventing the fields
understanding some of the biases human
decision-making
now machines are making more and more
decisions you see a day where we can and
should be delegating more of our
decisions to machines would that be a
better world would that be a less biased
world well I mean I think it's fairly
clear in the trends that we're seeing
that machine's algorithms have been
better than human judgments wherever the
comparison has been done for a long time
I mean there are hundreds of studies
documenting that and and actually the
algorithms don't even have to be very
complicated because human judgment is
typically so bad in in complex situation
with the what seems to be happening in
AI and that's you know what fascinates
me about it is that AI is clearly doing
better than the linear algorithms that
have been doing better than humans and
so there is that the potential for AI
making judgments better than humans is
mean that that is just going to happen
and it's going to happen in in
interesting places it's going to happen
in major decisions like for example
major business decisions
I could imagine module where and it's
going to happen that is going to have
the ability of evaluating a merger if al
you ating an acquisition better possibly
then then people are doing and what will
that do to our structure what will that
do to leadership what will that do to
organizations is a question that they're
already being used as we know
Institute's like helping with hiring
decisions bridgewire tagged by but one
of the concerns that Ryan brought up I
think Andrea listed is one of the three
big concerns Kate Crawford's it's
written about it is that some of these
systems end up having a lot of built-in
bias as they run well any system that is
modeled of the human judgments is going
to show human biases only that's that's
clear if you want to have the advantages
of modeling human judgments and
improving on it but at the same time
obeying certain moral constraints like
no discrimination ism then you have to
build that in you have to build that in
as a corrective but I I think that in
look I mean many of which we call
discrimination biases they are their
import because they are predictably
valid
I mean profiling profiling exists for a
reason it's not it has some elements of
predictive validity
you're going to build something that is
just trying to be predictive it's going
to do things that socially we are very
uncomfortable with and we'll have to
turn we're dealing with it maybe you
know fairness and other factors could
enter as well as predictive ability
validity but that will have to be built
in if if you're thinking of that
algorithm replacing human judgment you
and you want to build fairness into them
in some way and that is not going to
happen by merely finding the best
predictive solutions you are going to
have to impose constraints on the
solution are you more optimistic that we
can do that with machines and we've been
we can do removing biases from humans oh
yes I'm I'm really not very optimistic
about changing human nature I don't see
any reason to assume that the human
nature is going to change and clearly
with AI there are possibilities of
creating agents which are different I
was going to say who but agents at which
far different from the way that that
humans are and and the possibility of
designing something that is better than
human judgment that's an exciting
possibility and you seem pretty
optimistic about her well I mean I I see
no reason I see no reason to limit the
prediction about what can happen about
what can be modeled when one one very
simple difference between a human
judgment and algorithms is that
algorithms are noise free that is you
present an algorithm with the same
problem twice we are going to get the
same output there is a huge amount of
noise in human decision-making at all
levels
you know underwriters I mean I've been
studying this problem for the last few
years there's a huge amount of noise the
advantage of algorithm over humans that
has been documented in those hundreds of
studies is primarily
because algorithms are noise free and
now in addition to there being no is
free they are based on very large
databases then yes there is a lot of
potential well we're just about out of
time I can't help but you've been
smiling during this entire interview in
fact every time I see you you're smiling
you've been studying among other things
happiness research is there a causal
link one way or the other there or is it
a spurious correlation no doing
happiness research has nothing to do
with it I've just been enjoying myself
this is a great day great well we've
been enjoying very much as well thank
you very much for staying this time with
us
[Applause]
[Music]